all right Tupac but I am a Concrete Rose
looped in the garden I refuse to pose I
ain't a killer
these kids need someone to show that who
you are is enough and we ain't gotta
play Roll
that's a scene from the movie on the
come up about an aspiring teen rapper
named Bree it was based on the New York
Times best-selling novel of the same
name by author Angie Thomas she also
wrote the best sellers that you give and
Concrete Rose now Thomas is out with her
first fantasy novel which is also her
first book geared toward middle
schoolers it's called Nick Blake in the
remarkables the manifesto of Prophecy it
tells the story of a girl with magical
powers who grows on a mission to save
her dead and uncover family secrets
Angie Thomas Angie Thomas is with us
right now first on CBS mornings how you
doing I am wonderful thank you so much
for having me of course good to have you
back now you posted a video of your
younger self on Instagram writing this
kid with the big collar and thick
eyebrows both the fantasy book and she
always wanted to read how does it feel
to have this book out into the world oh
it feels great also shout out to my mom
who all those years ago had me glam
ready not knowing that
but no it feels awesome this is
something I've always wanted to do I
loved fantasy books growing up but I
really saw people in them who looked
like me I didn't see black girls as the
main characters going on these magical
adventures and I used to wonder why is
that and so as an adult I said hmm well
why not make that so why not write that
book that little Angie would have loved
to have read and even said it somewhere
that she knows so part of the book takes
place in Jackson Mississippi which you
know it doesn't seem like a magical
place but for me it was growing up and
so I get to make it magical in this book
plus I get to unveil like a big secret
about Jackson there's a volcano under
Jackson and nobody knows a lot of people
don't know that wait really
there is a real inactive volcano under
the city of Jackson so I got to explore
that in the book too and I know Jackson
kids are going to be like what oh
what I love about this though is that
you spin this fantasy world though using
the real African-American folklore so
tell us why that was important to you oh
that was super important um growing up I
love the folk tales like the people
could fly
um Virginia Hamilton let um made that a
well-known folktale through her story
um I love the story of John Henry I love
the story of hi John the Conqueror all
these magical figures
um and they were so important to me just
as important as maybe Greek mythology
was to other kids and so I really wanted
to bring that in and show those people
show these characters but also show the
origins of these stories and what they
came from and what they represent they
didn't just represent pain they
represented hope they represented magic
and that's something that kids need to
know and it's something that kids can
take pride in but also something that
can Inspire them one of my favorite
lines is
um it says you are the only gift you
need so
the fantasy part is one thing but that's
a deeply personal thing we all need to
hear whether we're in middle middle
schoolers you're right about that John
yeah absolutely that's a huge theme
throughout the book throughout the
series
um because Nick has this magical ability
called the gift but her dad wants her to
know look that's not all that you are
you're more than that you're more than
just magic you are magic yourself you
are a gift and so many of our kids don't
recognize that they are gifts themselves
what they can do what they are capable
of doing is a gift to their family to
the world and I hope that this book
inspires them and lets them know that
and reminds them of that now that was
inspired by your own dad who told you
that right yeah are you hoping that you
know readers they look at this they read
this not only is their fantasy there's
also history I mean you talk about the
Underground Railroad Harriet Tubman I
mean there's that history interwoven
with this incredible world of dragons
and Magic absolutely it was it was
important for me to bring those things
in especially here now we're in a time
where so many people don't necessarily
want to talk to kids about history but
it's important we talk about people like
Harriet Tubman and the things that she
did to help so many it's important we
talk about these things it's important
we talk about where we've been so we
know where we're going and I wanted to
still bring that into this magical world
and show that you know even in the midst
of magic there were still real people
who were doing real important things and
that's important given that there's both
being poured off the shelves of some of
these schools you're working on part two
yeah yeah of course yes one of the top
10 most banned books um you work in a
part two I am you are I am I am can you
give us a little bit of an idea of where
this is going I I will say there's a big
twist in the first book so I can't spoil
it there's a huge Twist of course the
reactions to the twist have been amazing
so far um but in the second book we get
to explore that twist a little bit more
and we get to explore this this magical
world a bit more and we get to see the
schools and things like that so I'm
super super excited we also get to see
some other magical cities so I'm super
excited about that Andrew Thomas thank
you for being the gift and sharing your
gift with us and thank you for your
contributions to education and culture
it's much needed the book is incredible
Nick and the remarkables is on sale now